- [Carlton] Dad?
- [Dad] Yes, Carlton?
- [Carlton] There's something I gotta know.
And I don't want you to spare my feelings.
I can handle the truth.
- [Dad] Okay son, you have my word.
What's on your mind?
- [Carlton]  When I grow up,
will I be able to grow a beard like that?
- You're a Lassiter.
And Lassiter men have been
growing legendary facewigs
for generations.
It's a king's beard, borne in your blood,
perfected through centuries.
But never forget, it's not
the beard that makes the king.
- I know, I know.
It's the queen.
- That's right, son.
We're almost there.
(ominous music)
- Dad?
Dad?
Dad, where are you?
(heartbeat beats)
Don't look at me!
Dad!
- [Chief Lassiter] This is
Chief Lassiter, shots fired.
I'm down.
I've been ambushed and shot.
Multiple times.
I need backup, immediately.
(intense music)
(gasping)
- Hold it.
Please, I have a family.
(click)
- [Dad] Carlton, do you
remember why you're here?
Think, son, think.
(dramatic music)
(gun bangs)
(air whooshing)
(ambulance sirening)
- [Dispatcher] We have an
officer down, all units respond,
2016 Parkinson Road, situation critical,
suspect still at large,
approach with extreme caution.
(rock music)
- [Both] Surprise!
- (yelling loudly)
- Surprise, surprise!
- What is wrong with you two?
- Check it out.
- [Carlton] What is that?
- That is gift for you.
(dog whines)
- Meet Morrissey, the rescue dog,
here to rescue you from
your own handsomeness.
- That dog's Chief Hicks'.
- He was.
- He kept biting our daughter.
- Perfection gnawing is
what the vet called it.
- He called it rabies, Shawn.
- Either way, the Chief, Gus, and I,
have come to a little agreement.
- She set him loose in my
office and sped away in her car.
(dog landing)
Then you called us to come down here,
and the whole thing just
felt like a win-win.
(gnawing)
- That dog is eating my foot.
- Morrissey!
- Stop it.
- (hissing)
- Oh, excuse me, Carlton, I
didn't realize you had visitors.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, sorry, no pets.
- Pets, I'm sorry, I, (laughing)
that's Morrissey, he's a therapy dog.
- Does he have a vest?
- He does, though he prefers
to call it a waistcoat.
I think you'll find it all checks out.
- Hmm, this is an old Theraflu T-shirt
with tape over the FLU and P-Y in Sharpie.
- You're good, one point for you, Delores.
(chuckling) My name is Shawn Spencer,
and this is my partner, Bill Poopingtons.
- No, Shawn?
- What?
- Sidebar.
- All right.
- Carlton, what is happening right now?
- Let it go.
- Yes.
- Bill Poopingtons?
What kind of nickname is that?
- Transylvania Dutch, why?
- No Shawn, no more
embarrassing nicknames,
especially in front of
peers and professionals.
- Gus, don't be the night
your dad feel asleep inside your mom.
- (tsks)
- We can't just stop doing bits
we've been doing for 10 years.
We have fans, they have expectations,
there'll be a huge backlash.
- Shawn, we are two dumbasses,
we do not have fans.
From now on, I do the nicknames.
- No no no, absolutely
not, that's disgusting.
Counter-proposal.
You have right of refusal
until we land on one you like.
It's a band-aid, but, okay, for now.
- I'm terribly sorry, Delores,
what I meant to say was,
my name is Shawn Spencer, this
is my full-fledged partner,
All the Pips in One.
- Accepted.
Hello!
- Could you fellas take
a little walk with me?
- Lassie, is that what I think it is?
(laughing)